[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and this is the channel where snoopers
go and snoop scoopers go and scoop
and as always poopers go poop episode 7
of one division ended with a bigger
cliffhanger than the cliffhanging
in the movie cliffhanger and throughout
this video we're going to be giving our
theories for the future of the show
now first up i want to discuss what i
think the general aesthetic of episode 8
as a whole will be
before episode 7 ed twitter user
learn1888
asked whether people thought the entry
would be a flashback
or the modern family episode at the time
i said i thought that we'd get the
modern family one
a big cliffhanger ending and that eight
would be a flashback
before dealing with the consequences of
said cliffhanger for the finale
after watching 7 i definitely think that
i'm on the money with this
and i believe that in 8 we will get a
flashback that probably begins with
agatha's origin story
during the salem witch trials people
have a lot of questions over the
character
and therefore i think that it will be
the best way to start off the entry
and something that is in the same vein
as monica's after this snap
now in the comics agatha is a witch
that's over 10 000 years old
and i kind of think that this will be
skipped over and instead we'll just see
that she was born in the 1600s
and then became a witch just before the
trials began
during them she will marry her soul to
the devil and this is why she said her
and ralph's anniversary was on june 2nd
aka the date that they started this is
something we've banged on about for a
while in our videos
but i keep coming back to it purely
because witches were often referred to
as the bride of satan
and as we now know for definite she's a
witch it just makes so much sense
after that i can see the episode
showcasing wonder going to the sword
facility to take vision's body
after finding out that it's been
weaponized against his will
as vision technically isn't a human he
doesn't have the same rights as one
and i think that this will be the straw
that breaks the camel's back in terms of
wonders grief
she seemed to be accepting of his death
at the end of end game and in order to
warrant the creation of the hex
i think there needs to be a reveal that
he's being used for some ultron terrier
motives
that that pun was meant to be ulterior
motives with ultron in there
look it worked on paper just not in the
video we probably will see her storming
the sword facility from her point of
view
which i actually think was shown in the
trailers i'm kind of torn on whether she
will take the body or not
i think that it might be revealed that
she actually left the facility without
it
and that hayward still has it in a draw
which has caused a lot of confusion
this could explain why vision isn't able
to leave the hex
however as always i'm not hedging my
bets on just one thing yet
and it is possible that wanda did take
it but because she didn't have the mind
stone
she wasn't able to resurrect him thus
agnes came along
and showed how to bring him back to life
and in doing so she also
taught her how to create the hex it's
also possible that the grim reaper
was involved in this due to his helmet
appearing in episode 2
though that could just be an easter egg
that links back to the comics
now agnes or rather the person who was
agatha
all along had ultron terrier mo
i'm start i'll stop with that she had
ulterior motives and also wanted wanda
to create some powerful beings
and that's kept her imprisoned in the
hex while she subliminally suggested to
her that she have
children i think episode 9 will then
show the defeat of agatha before
wonder and vision have to fight for
their home against sword
in the trailers we see wonder wearing
what looks to be the same scarlet hoodie
that she had on in episode
7 so that just makes the most sense to
me though
that scene could also be the cliffhanger
that ends episode 8.
now after seeing agatha's lair in an
empire strikes back-esque ending
i think it's safe to assume that there's
more than one evil witch in the town
due to all of the varying sigils it
appears that there might be several
witches operating in the area
and if you know agatha from the comics
then you'll be well aware that she
headed up a coven
i actually think that the women's
meeting was the witches getting together
and that we will learn dottie and co are
also in on it too
they're doing it for the children
because which is actually a
kid and this is why there's so many
missing as well
i know that's a bit of a wild theory but
if it's true then the story about agnes
buying a kid
it holds way more meaning and that joke
is pretty messed up when you really look
into it
now another thing that you have to be
aware about is that covens all worship
someone or something
and thus i do think that there will be
an even bigger bad behind it all
if you've been watching my breakdowns
and you know i've kind of gone back and
forth over whether mephisto is in the
show or not
and i definitely think that there's
someone that we aren't seeing which
could of course be ralph
in the lair there was a goat's head
which is typically a symbol of satan
as well as some faces that look like the
devils
i kind of have a feeling that what
disney will do is that they'll set up a
big bad behind everything
that kind of slots into the tv shows too
this is why a devil also appears in the
stained glass window during the loki
trailer
and i am holding out hope that mephisto
is linked in some way
let's be honest if there's not then i'm
going to look very stupid
but this approach worked for thanos and
it kind of gives the shows their own big
villain that will keep us coming back
for more
now whenever i bring this up the first
comment is normally about how disney
also want their shows to play well in
china
which doesn't typically allow any occult
imagery in their media
if i was disney i'd just change the name
mephisto to nightmare in the subtitles
and hope that no one noticed but it is
possible that they just mush
both mephisto and nightmare together and
then call them nightmare
they did something similar in iron man 2
but the creative team actually combined
both crimson dynamo and whiplash
to make the character whiplash now if
they do squash the two together
i don't think it'll give anyone whiplash
if they just mix the two
and the pair do have a similar sort of
skill set in many ways
now if they do go the nightmare out i
would absolutely love to see him played
once more
by mark hamill warstu did a video on
this the other day
and reminded me that hamill had played
nightmare in the pass-through animation
from paul bettany we know that there's
still one big character coming down the
line
that no one has guessed yet so what if
the luke skywalker in the mandalorian
level cameo that they've been teasing
is actually none other than luke
skywalker and he plays the villain
before going off to do doctor strange 2.
i would absolutely love to see that but
another possibility is that it's al
pacino
who did admit earlier in the week that
he'd met with kevin feige
if the kiana reeves ghost rider rumors
are true then i'd love to see pacino
playing mephisto
just because the fanboy in me adores the
devil's advocate
and i would love to see that team up
once more as you know what it's one of
my favorite films
also we know that mephisto's first
appearance was as a fly
and though there wasn't a fly in
agatha's house
there was that kikada or whatever it's
called
i don't know i'm gonna be honest yeah in
my last breakdown i called it a fly
and so many of you said i was wrong and
that it's actually a
kicarda the thing is yeah i look this up
and they're actually close to extinction
in england
and i've never come across one so i just
thought it was a fly however
what i do know is that if you're
enjoying this video yeah please please
subscribe to the channel
and finally we know that vision hasn't
appeared on screen with loki as of yet
either
and as we know from the trailers on his
show he will be working with the tva
i would love to see him pop up at the
end of the series as the hex definitely
falls under the type of thing that they
cover and it would be a great way to
just link the shows together
now episode 7 ended on a big cliffhanger
not only in the agatha reveal
but also the post-credits scene itself i
don't know about you but
after i frantically rushed through all
of the other episodes
looking to see if they'd had one too but
luckily there wasn't any
and i got to keep my channel however the
post-credits scene was very important
and it showed what appeared to be monica
finding agatha's basement
before being stopped by evan peters's
quicksilver
he said snooper is gonna snoop and we
then cut to black
now i think most people assume that he's
actually working for agatha
and that he just caught monica however
shout outs to leo pogia who contacted me
on friday
and said that he might actually have
been referring to himself snipping
that he too may be looking about the
property quicksilver is a super fast
mutant
that could easily run upon monica and
kill her faster than you should click
the like button on this video
and it seems super weird that he'd just
appear like that when he didn't have to
potentially pietro is also looking for
his sister
and he just came across monica whilst
this was going on
in the agatha all along scene we do see
her controlling him as he arrives at the
door
and therefore i don't think he's
actually working alongside her
potentially he's being possessed by the
character
or potentially he's actually a nice guy
who just likes looking in people's
houses
now i hope he's not a villain as i think
it's such a shame to be so close to
getting the x-men in the mcu without
doing any major recasts
and it just feels like we'll never be
able to trust any actors coming across
if the first one is worse than agatha
pushing back black widow every three
months
i know it was you delaying these movies
all along agatha
i know anyway those are some of the
major fan theories
and i wasn't even gonna post a video
today but i had so many things floating
around in my head that i just had to get
this out
i know as soon as it goes live that i
think crap i forgot to mention the
entire thing about amadeus cho being in
it
but it'll be too late by that point and
there's no way that i can possibly edit
that in
however you still have time and can
write whatever theories you have in the
comments section below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 28th of february
in which we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase 3 4k
box set to our subscribers all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the theories
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
episode 7
which will be linked on screen right now
it's just past 1 million views
and because of it that breakdown is
worth the breakdown of my marriage
definitely give it a watch and with that
other way thank you for sitting through
the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace